as we all know the covet 19 pandemic
continues to have a profound effect on
the mental health of many across canada
if you or someone you know is struggling
with mental health issues resources are
available
the wellness together canada portal
gives everyone across our country access
to a wide range of free services online
by phone or by text messaging in
multiple languages
we also recently launched pocketwell a
free companion app to wellness together
in canada that is now available freely
for download
you can use this application to complete
self-assessments track your mood and men
attract your mood and mental well-being
and get access to resources and supports
24 7.
2 million canadians have already used
that support with a total of almost 6
million free and confidential sessions
i encourage all of us to take care of
our mental health and reach out to those
that may be struggling
as we all know the best tool to our
fight against kovid kobit 19 continues
to be vaccination
so far 82
of all canadians of all ages have taken
this important step and are now fully
vaccinated 80 48
have now received their booster dose
and close to 53 percent of children age
5 to 11 have received their first dose
if you have not already done so i urge
you to make an appointment online
or visit a vaccination clinic in your
community as soon as possible there are
vaccines for everyone
it is a simple but very important way to
protect ourselves our kids and our local
health care services
presentations
even though it may seem as though the
worst of omicron may be behind us we all
want to continue to exercise prudence
and to follow public health advice
thank you merci and doctors over to you
merci monica
although daily reported cases remain at
record high levels and continue to
underestimate the true number of
infections
multiple indicators suggest infections
have peaked at the national level
including daily case counts test
positivity
the rt or effective reduction number and
wastewater surveillance trends
as of january 26 the seven day average
case count of over 19 000 cases reported
daily is a 28 decrease compared to the
previous week and incidence is declining
across all age groups
as well although the latest seven day
average of lab test positivity remain
high at 19 percent it has been gradually
decreasing in recent weeks including by
14
compared to the previous week
this reassures us that individual
efforts including the layering of
personal protections like masking and
limiting in-person contacts together
with population-based public health
measures to reduce contact rates are
helping to slow transmission and
mitigate severe illness trends
presently lagging indicators are still
rising over the same periods an average
of close to 10
800 people with covert 19 are being
treated in our hospitals each day
including over 1
200 in intensive care units and 168
deaths were reported daily
this is why it continues to be important
to limit spread as much as possible
getting up to date with the best
available protection for covet 19
vaccines substantially lowers the risk
of severe illness for those eligible
getting an mrna booster has been shown
to provide additional protection against
infection
but most importantly results in very
good protection against severe illness
resulting in hospitalization from
omicron
health authorities in canada have
continued to monitor vaccine safety data
for millions of covid19 vaccinations and
regularly update vaccine recommendations
this week canada's national advisory
committee on immunization on nasi
updated guidance on mra vaccination for
children aged 5 to 11 years on tuesday
and for adolescents aged 12 to 17 years
today
children and adolescents remain at low
risk of severe outcomes compared to
older individuals however the
substantially higher rates of omicron
infection have resulted in greater
number of children with covet 19
requiring hospitalizations
than previously
hence nasty's latest advice underscores
important opportunities for enhancing
protection in these age groups
specifically for those without
contraindication to the vaccines
nasty now strongly recommends that
children aged five to 11 years receive a
complete to those primary series of the
pfizer 10 microgram pediatric mrna
covert 19 vaccine with at least eight
weeks between the first and second dose
nasi is also recommending a third dose
for moderately to severely
immunocompromised children in this age
group
for adolescents aged 12 to 17 years nasi
continues to strongly recommend a
complete primary series of mrna covert
19 vaccines including a third dose for
those who are moderately to severely
immunocompromised
in addition for adolescents who are at
high risk due to biological and or
social risk factors nasi now recommends
a booster dose of an authorized mrna
covert 19 vaccine may be offered at
least six months after the completion of
a primary covet-19 vaccine series
these include adolescents aged 12 to 17
years who have an underlying medical
condition that may put them at high risk
of severe illness due to covet 19
including those who are
immunocompromised and who have already
received a three dose primary series
those who are residents of congregate
living settings including shelters group
homes
quarters for migrant workers
correctional facilities or
those belonging to racialized or
marginalized communities
disproportionately affected by covert
19.
up-to-date vaccination is recommended
for better protection in all eligible
people this is particularly important
for parents guardians in close contact
in order to help protect children and
adolescents who can't be vaccinated or
have conditions that place them at risk
for severe outcomes
however as no vaccines 100 effective it
is important for everyone to continue to
use personal protective measures such as
wearing a good quality snug fitting mask
avoiding crowding and improving
ventilation in indoor spaces thank you
merci merch
constitutes
estimation
the protection
thank you mcwitch
merci thank you please press star one at
this time if you have a question
our first question is from abigail bimen
from global news
please go ahead
good morning thanks for taking my
question i'm wondering if you can talk
about ba2 what we know about
how many cases there are in canada what
people should know about it and how
concerned you are
dr dan
thank you for the question yes um our
national microbiology lab together with
provincial and territorial labs have
been tracking this
particular
sub
lineage if you like of
omicron
and
we know that we we've detected it since
november of last year we're one of the
first countries to actually pick up on
this variant as well
and we have
at least over 100
identifications 77 of them from the
national microbiology lab and some
further reporting from provinces and
territories as well
we're still learning of course about
this sub-variant but
at the at the moment the international
data suggests that it could potentially
have an increased
advantage on spread but that doesn't
seem to be any specific increase
in
hospitalizations or
the severe outcomes compared to
ba1 but we'll be tracking that very
closely
i'm wondering if there if you're
concerned that that it may that having
increased cases may extend the current
wave that we're in and if you could also
provide context as to if we've seen it
since november uh you know is it picking
up speed now or is it of more concern
now in january
well we're still monitoring this very
closely the vast vast majority of our
identifications are the ba1 uh but that
doesn't mean ba
2.2 couldn't pick up later on
is there's always a possibility that
that could occur but we don't actually
know that yet at the moment is is really
a ba1
omega wave
other countries have observed i think
different trends some have seen
increases but not very much
and other countries such as denmark have
seen a greater increase and that could
be due to a number of factors including
whether it got introduced into a
particular pocket of
underprotected populations so all of
that is still being worked out
as i've said you know getting to
perhaps the peak is one thing but coming
down the other side of the wave um
includes a lot of people who could get
infected and some of them could
potentially be infected with uh ba 0.2
next question
thank you
so much
um
foreign
perspective
and trying
um
[Music]
um
our next question is from annie berger
oliver from cdb national news please go
ahead
thank you for taking my question um bc
in ontario have said that we need to
learn to live with omicron in bc they
are now treating omicron more like the
common cold do you believe that this is
the right approach and is this what the
federal government is now advising
dr dan
yes i think um you know it is a very
difficult balance but i think the
provinces are trying to
balance the overwhelming number of cases
going on in the communities and the fact
that you can't really do case and
contact management
similar to some of the other respiratory
viruses so uh focusing on um more and
more on having people stay home when
they're sick and
really
heighten up their personal protective
measures uh because it's very difficult
for public health to do you know
individual case contact management and
so um and this i think uh was emphasized
as being as uh the characteristic of
this omicron wave and how they're
managing it
what we have to do is to take stock i
think when
we see this omicron wave descent as to
what may happen after the omicron wave
and we are looking forward to get
gathering some more information
including um from zero prevalence
studies on the level of immunity in the
population for example in order for us
to get a better handle on uh what the
next months will be like but i'm
certainly cautiously optimistic
as i've said um i think last week um but
uh we i think it would be great to be
driven by a bit more uh data
i i think that um
it's quite possible
that the omicron
virus will continue to circulate but
will become manage more manageable i
think that's one of the indicators i'm
looking for is whether the hospitals
and icus and the health system is able
to manage any kind of resurgence and and
those would be the most important um
indicators but i think all local and
provincial health departments have a
really difficult job trying to balance
the
of course the disruption in society
versus managing the surges
thank you and my follow-up question is
for both dr tam and minister duklow
many of the people involved in the
trucker convoy that's heading to ottawa
are openly in fact anti-vaccine some are
encouraging people to ignore mass
mandates and some are encouraging
restaurants to ignore public health
restrictions and to reopen early i'm
wondering what do you believe is the
potential impact of this messaging and
what does it say about the challenge now
and moving forward around buy-in to
public health advice and guidance
i may start and then
turn to dr tam for
links between the public messaging
the actions that people take
individually and the impact of those
actions on our collective ability to
exit from uh from kobe 19. first about
the messaging as i was saying in french
just a moment ago the convoy of which we
should be speaking is a convoy of
everyone being on board knowing that the
enemy is not vaccination the enemy is
kobet 19 and the best tool to fight this
enemy is to be vaccinated we have the
fortune in
we have had a fortune
in on earth you know because of the
great progress that science and
scientists made just a few months ago we
have the great fortune of having a key
tool in our toolbox to fight kovite 19
omicron not only in the short term but
in the longer term we have the fortune
in canada of having immense access
universal access to vaccination we have
more doses than we need now to vaccinate
everyone with a booster dose so we have
this fortune in canada
but with this fortune comes a collective
responsibility we know it's it's we're
all tired we know it it's sometimes a
bit not difficult to be mindful of the
importance of following public health
measures and being vaccinated vaccinated
vaccination is something that you know
takes some time and no they may disrupt
the uh
you know the the the agenda of a person
or a family for some time but now it it
it's the only
tool for which we know that there is a
definite benefit not only in the short
and in the longer term so the convoy is
a convoy that we need to
to to to be on in a peaceful respectful
manner looking forward to exiting
through this
exiting from the crisis because of
vaccination an individual
measure
to be protect protect each other
ourselves but also a benevolent measure
a measure of unity to protect others to
protect other workers to protect our
supply chains protect our economy and to
protect all many uh
all of the many uh workers and
businesses that are currently affected
because of the lockdown and public
health measures at the particular time
dr tan
yes i think it's it's throughout the
pandemic and certainly since the start
of the vaccination program it has been
really important to address this and
this this information and using multiple
means to do that including debunking uh
misinformation as as rapidly as we can
and potentially doing pre-banking which
is to prevent
disinformation and misinformation before
they even start so i think that i'm
particularly pleased yesterday for
example
when signs up first
children's health care canada and
other
experts as well came together to answer
questions that parents have on
kids vaccination for example so
providing um experts to uh they're out
there to answer
questions very legitimate questions that
people have about vaccines and their
safety in particular is continues to be
extremely important and i think i want
to emphasize that canada does have one
of the highest vaccination
rates uh globally and we we certainly
could boost our booster rates but um i
just want to thank everybody and
including workers in the transportation
sector who did roll up the sleeves and
really get vaccinated and for the
small
proportion of people who haven't got
their vaccines
we do have to make sure they have access
to vaccination
programs and also answered
some very legitimate questions that may
have and continue to do so
and um vaccinations are actually very
important to maintain the business
continuity of our critical
infrastructures
thank you
okay we have time for one more question
just a reminder to keep your answers uh
short please thank you
thank you our last question is from mia
rabson from the canadian press please go
ahead
hi yes dr tim i'm wondering if you can
explain why nasty advice did not go to
all teenagers to get a booster shot
which is what the recommendation is in
the united states
thank you for that question and i also
have dr tunis on the line from the nasty
um secretariat as needed but um of
course nasi has been very thoughtful
throughout this pandemic in terms of
weighing out the risk and benefits and
right now this is the off-label
recommendation
for the use of boosters in the
adolescent age group so a boosted dose
for the 12 to 17 year old without
the medical or social risk factors is
not recommended due to the generally low
risk of severe covert 19 outcomes in
adolescents who've received a complete
primary series
and um so so i think that's partly
the reason but certainly for those with
the higher higher risk conditions and
circumstances
it is something that
can be offered
and nasty will monitor the evolving
science this is their recommendation
right now that doesn't mean it couldn't
shift but
they will monitor the evolving evidence
and update the guidance as needed
they are also going to be looking at
advice on recommending the timing of
boost of those who's following an actual
saskov2 infection so that might also
come into play in terms of the decision
on
additional doses
and um dr tam i i can also add to that
that um the the committee is really
underscoring also the importance of that
primary series for all adolescents so
for those who have not yet been
immunized um that that would be an
important action to take and in general
we're seeing really good durability of
the primary series the first two doses
against even omicron in canada and also
in other countries
so that's something that the committee
is monitoring very closely and we're
working with provincial territorial
surveillance partners to understand
exactly what the risk of severe disease
is in adolescence after the primary
series um so far the signals that we're
seeing in general of the population
level is that it is still
holding up well
and as dr tam mentioned it's the early
days in this adolescent booster program
the evidence is um is just starting to
come in from countries like israel who
have already initiated a program
and while they are seeing some
significant
benefit
um i ascertaining exactly what that
benefit will be
is still hard to do at this point so
we'll learn more over time and as as
we've seen with the pediatric
recommendations for 5 to 11 this week
that have evolved and at this point
nasty is now strongly recommending that
there might be a point at which um the
program is extended more broadly or it
might be that for the majority of um
adolescents there's actually not a need
for a booster dose so it's i think early
days but the committee is very actively
monitoring the space
thank you i'm wondering if uh just a
quick follow-up to that if you can
clarify when you say that the doses are
holding up well if you mean to infection
or severe disease but my actual second
question uh dr tam obviously there is a
large number of protesters arriving in
ottawa this weekend regarding
vaccinations particularly mandates for
truckers at the border i'm wondering if
you could explain what data and science
was used to decide that a vaccine
mandate at the border needed to be fur
like go further and start not stop
exempting certain people including
truckers and what tracking we're doing
to see what impact that uh that mandate
is actually having on both the spread of
omicron or cohen in general um and on
getting people vaccinated
did you want to go first matt yeah sure
i'll go first um yeah just so just to
clarify
against severe disease so the the
primary series continues to perform
well we're seeing in the 75 to 80
percent range of protection against
severe disease from omicron um in
ontario and that's very similar to
what's being observed in other countries
as well and there does seem to be some
an incremental benefit of booster doses
on top of that but in the adolescent age
group we don't yet know what that
incremental benefit would be and it
might be actually the adolescents are
protected very well and maybe are at
that top end of that severe disease
protection and and they continue to
generally be at low risk of severe
disease from infection overall so
you'll see a priority focus of nasty and
their recommendations around severe
disease understanding that
you know at this point in the pandemic
that continues to be the priority
objective is trying to to focus programs
around minimizing severe disease
infection is
is also always welcomed if we can
prevent that but it's not the emphasis
of the program
yes um and on the border measures of
course no layers of border measures are
completely uh effective they i always
think of the you know swiss cheese and
analogy where every slice of
swiss cheese have some holes and then
layering on those protections
are some of the uh approaches at the
border and vaccination and um the the
requirements has formed a
very significant layer of our border
strategy overall and that's with the
improved
availability
and the
access to vaccinations i think you've
seen that the government has increased
those facts and vaccine requirements as
time goes by because we just know how
effective vaccines are
we
have not tracked specifically you know
we've been tracking of course that's
positive for two rates amongst
vaccinated and unvaccinated individuals
but we don't sort of disaggregate that
information
in terms of
whether someone is a transportation
worker or not so i can't
give you that information and just uh
just the last word based on what we've
just heard which most of us had heard
and had understood earlier
we're all on the same convoy to exit
covet 19 and we know that the best road
to do that is the vaccination road
we understand
now there is frustration around covalent
19
but we also know that the only way to
exit covet 19 is to get vaccinated
okay and on these words i'm told this is
all the time we have so this ends the
press conference thank you very much for
your participation merci beaucoup
especially weekend have a good